Mick Mulvaney held that briefing
yesterday to make an unprecedented
announcement and triggered even more
controversy he said the g7 summit an
important gathering of world leaders
will be held next June at the
president's Florida resort prompting new
criticism that the president is using
his office to enrich himself chief
Washington correspondent major Garrett
is at the White House with along this
story major a couple things how in the
world is this okay number one and two
what's at stake here for the president
well the short White House answered a
question one Gail is the president's not
gonna profit therefore it's not
inappropriate or improper what's at
stake the merging of two intense lines
of criticism of this White House both
with constitutional implications as we
just heard there's already the ongoing
House impeachment inquiry investigating
whether or not the president used the
powers of the presidency to benefit
himself politically in Ukraine now with
this doral g7 summit announcement more
evidence lawmakers say in an existing
lawsuit accusing the president of using
those self same powers to profit from
the presidency just look at the terrible
foreign corruption of the Biden's the
White House announcement comes as the
president has repeatedly accused his
Democratic rival Joe Biden of self
dealing the Biden's got rich while
America got robbed it's not the only
place it's the best place acting chief
of staff Mick Mulvaney said there is
nothing improper about Doral hosting the
summit of foreign leaders because mr.
Trump will not earn a profit I don't
care about according to the Constitution
all federal employees are prohibited
from accepting any gift or fee from a
foreign government with Doral we have a
series of magnificent buildings we have
incredible conference rooms the
ballrooms are among the biggest in
Florida Doral is prominent among mr.
Trump's us-based properties he
reportedly took out a 125 million dollar
loan to buy it he's got a lot more
invested in Doral than he does in say
the Trump Hotel in New York or other
places because this is his money and
he's on the hook for the loan Jonathan
O'Connell of the Washington Post said
Darrell's financial situation is
stressed with net operating income
falling 69 percent
between 2015 and 2017 next year's g7
summit will come to Doral when it needs
revenue badly June is part of the club's
seasonal slump when visitors tend to
shun Florida's heat and humidity you're
going to have not only the business that
you're going to get but you are going to
have the greatest advertisement for our
property you could ever have some White
House officials worried about the optics
of choosing Doral for the g7 summit but
president Trump was undeterred those
same officials say the president never
influenced the site selection process
but readily acknowledged Tony his
advocacy publicly and here could not be
ignored and that may have made the
difference major thank you very much